we're here in the Mala Mala Game Reserve
of South Africa to discover the
fascinating lifestyle of the woe of the
leopard unlike their lion cousins
leopards are solitary creatures staking
out turf about the only time they are by
themselves is well I mean what male can
resist a comely female leopard
especially one with fresh kill while she
climbs a tree to enjoy her meal he
demonstrates that chivalry isn't dead by
chasing off a pesky hyena after all this
the female tries to seduce the male but
he basically ignores her because he
knows she's not ready to mate and they
part company but only temporarily the
male knows when the female is really
really really ready to mate by the scent
of her territorial markers
now they'll mate from seventy to a
hundred times a day
for four five or even six days the
entire region becomes their honeymoon
suite the male roams his domain and the
female follows they're passionate out
cries unnerve sanam Holland's and they
scatter every which rang when their prey
almost run them over
the leopard lovers switch back into
hunting mode now here's something rare
collaboration two leopards bring down
the same Impala
after they part ways the female may give
birth about three months later but with
high mortality rates
a mother's large litter can be decimated
and only two or three Cubs survive
playing a bit of hide-and-seek
the mother might move her cubs every
single day to keep lions hyenas and even
male leopards from eating them at three
months old they're ready to take down
their own prey but it may take them two
years to master this incredible skill to
the point where it's an art form